So we're working backwards now.
Now we're back to Thanksgiving Thursday.
And Donald Trump finally took questions from
reporters, sort of technically, although he
didn't actually answer a single question in
a real way.
He did attack a reporter.
And we're going to look at that in a moment.
Trump didn't even hesitate to come out and
tell the lies that his flunkies and tools
and cronies and lawyers have been telling
for weeks about this election.
Now, I know that some of these clips have
blue flashes and some audio glitches.
They are not our glitches.
The master video we got of the event for some
reason contains some of these glitches.
Take a listen to this first clip.
And I'm serious.
If the media were honest and a big tech were
honest, which is totally not.
It's it's a terrible thing.
That whole Section 230 is a disgrace that
they even have it.
But big tech is totally dishonest.
If the media were honest and big tech was
fair, this wouldn't even be a contest.
And I would have won by a tremendous amount,
a tremendous amount.
And I did win by a tremendous amount.
But it hasn't been reported yet.
But people understand what's happened.
They know what happens now.
Of course, Donald Trump did not win by any
amount.
Never mind a tremendous one, but he continues
to say it.
And then he starts getting asked really specific
questions like, will you go to Joe Biden's
inauguration and check out how he handles
it?
Of course it is tradition.
Say, you know, it's tradition for previous
presidents to go to the next president's inauguration.
So will you.
And you don't want to say that yet.
But I mean, I know the answer.
I'll be honest.
I know the answer.
But I just don't want to say you look, a thing
like this possibly has never happened before,
but maybe people just didn't catch it.
But we've caught it.
But we've got we've got hundreds of thousands
of us, if I may say excuse me, excuse me,
if I may, when they don't allow a poll watcher,
which is a sacred person in our country, people
don't know what a poll watcher is.
A poll watcher is it's considered sacred in
our country when they throw them out of rooms.
But that's not true.
They didn't do this.
And when they put them in pet, your attorneys
admitted they didn't.
My attorneys did not admit anything.
This is this is really stuff for history books.
Will you go to the inauguration?
Well, listen, I one we caught them.
The poll watchers were in pens and they've
used the term corralled before, you know,
giving this idea that poll watchers were corralled
along with wild hogs and Steyr eating cereal
and grain from a trough.
Trump then casually saying they gave Biden
lots of votes that weren't really Biden votes.
Still not a shred.
I mean, not an iota of evidence for that claim.
They gave Biden a lot of votes that he would
never have gotten.
This is not a candidate that could get an
80, 80 million.
This is just not a candidate.
This is not a candidate to beat Barack Hussein
Obama with the black vote.
This is not a candidate who can beat Obama
with the black vote.
This is not a candidate that beat Hillary
Clinton to a pulp.
Just doesn't work that way.
Remember that all of those claims are spurious
and without evidence.
And every court has found that to be the case
so far.
Trump was then asked, despite your claims,
that it was rigged and stolen by Joe Biden,
if the Electoral College votes for Joe Biden,
will you step down and concede?
And this caused Trump to blow a gasket and
attack the reporter.
Just to be clear, if the Electoral College
votes for Joe Biden.
Well, if they do, they made a mistake because
this election was a fraud.
Just saying they said this election was a
fraud.
I mean, they have Biden beating Obama on Obama's
vote in areas that mattered in terms of the
election in swing states.
Yet he's losing to Obama all over the place,
but he's beating Obama in swing states, which
are the states that matter for purposes of
the election.
So, no, I can't say that at all.
I think it's a it's a possibility.
They're trying to look between you people.
Don't ask don't talk to me that way.
I mean, just you just a lightweight.
Don't talk to me that.
Don't talk to the president of the United
States.
Don't ever talk to the president that way.
This is actually very interesting because
people who are respected and are respectable,
they never in a million years have to tell
anybody, respect me.
Saying respect me is something you hear from
people who are difficult to respect, who aren't
commanding respect through their actions.
And Trump says, respect me.
Now, another sign of just this sort of shrunken
down intellectual smurf that that is Donald
Trump.
Trump then, of course, saying that, listen,
he doesn't believe the Georgia elections are
going to be fairly done.
And if this leads to Republicans simply not
showing up in the Georgia Senate races, that
would be great.
Take a listen.
Mr. President, if you don't think that the
presidential election was legitimate, you
think that it was stolen, what confidence
do you expect voters in Georgia to have when
they go to the polls to vote for, say, Luffler?
Well, I told them today, I think you're dealing
in a very fraudulent system.
I think.
I'm very worried about that.
They are tremendous people.
Kelly Lefler, David Perdue, a tremendous people.
They should be in the United States Senate.
They're desperately needed.
But I told them today, I said, listen, you
have a fraudulent system.
You have a system with the flick of a switch
or the putting in of a new chip can change
the course of history.
And you have to be very careful.
And again, the funny thing about this is there
is actually a Republican movement to boycott
the runoff elections in Georgia.
OK, great.
Have added that would help Democrats take
the Senate.
I encourage Republicans, if they really do
believe the system is fraudulent, then just
don't participate.
Leave the voting to those that will be voting
for Raphael Warnock and John USCIRF.
I would be glad to see that.
Trump also believes that Pennsylvania state
senators are going to overturn the election
and he falsely claims that he actually won
Georgia very easily in Philadelphia.
You take a look.
We've had excellent meetings with.
Senators from Pennsylvania, Republican senators
and others, and they're saying things they
know is dishonest, but they didn't know was
this dishonest.
And you'll see it all.
You'll see it all.
So we'll see.
Speaking of Georgia, I'll be going there.
I spoke with the two great senators.
They're great senators, Kelly and David.
I'll probably be going on Saturday.
We're looking for a site.
We're going to have a tremendous turnout and
we seem to always have a good turnout.
The people are very disappointed that we were
robbed.
Listen, Republicans in Pennsylvania are telling
Trump he won, so he must have won.
And Trump mentioning a rally in Georgia there.
He said Saturday people thought it meant this
past Saturday.
I guess it's going to be this coming Saturday,
December 5th.
I guess that is we will certainly cover it
live if it happens.
And then just a final moment of insanity.
Trump claiming that all of the election results
in Georgia, Michigan, Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
were fraud in a completely deranged outburst.
A signature is the reason they don't want
to show a signature.
This is very simple because we will find thousands
and thousands of very close race.
It's hair thin, but we'll find thousands and
thousands of discrepancies.
Fraud, why they aren't wanting to show those
signatures is amazing.
They're doing recounts and even in the recount,
they found thousands of votes that were off.
But now we want to look at the signatures
and you will find tens of thousands of false
ballots, frauds, forged ballots.
You'll see it all over.
You're going to see a lot of it.
And you go to Pennsylvania.
You saw the meeting we had yesterday with
Pennsylvania.
You saw people come up here.
They went to vote and they said, no, you can't
vote.
Somebody else already sent in a ballot and
a woman.
But this is happening tens of thousands of
times.
I think it was 600 and some odd thousand six
hundred and 87000 fraudulent votes cast in
Pennsylvania.
And I will tell you, the if you look at the
state House now, the Republican state House
is starting to see what's going on there.
But they've really known it for a long time.
When you go to Michigan and you look at what
happened in Wayne County in Detroit, I went
through a list.
So Trump just goes on and on claiming that
he really won everything.
There was a woman and there was a guy and
some irregularities.
Biden didn't really win is the take away.
And this is the derange stuff that, you know,
you would hope would never happen in the United
States.
Like as toxic as American politics is, you
wouldn't expect that it would get this bad,
except this time we did expect it.
And we were right to all of those Republican
hot take saying you guys are going overboard.
Trump's never going to do any of this.
He's doing all of it.
He's never conceded.
He's claiming he's won six or more states
that he lost.
He won't commit to going to the inauguration.
He won't stop filing lawsuit after lawsuit
to try to steal it.
Our most catastrophic predictions all came
true.
Incredibly.
Now the question is, what will he do in the
remaining time up until January 20th?
What a time
to
be alive, my friend.